[Music]
[Applause]
oh there he is Matt Damon Big Time
former sexiest man of the year and uh
actor film producer curse Goodwill
Hunting
he plays Sonny Vaccaro in the new movie
air that hits theaters on Wednesday
April 5th at what age did you get your
first pair of Air Jordans
uh that's a good question late late uh I
couldn't I I didn't really have the
disposable income for them uh in high
school when they came out uh so I think
I got I would have got them after
college actually I was wondering though
you grow up a Celtic fan they wore
Converse and I don't know if you
wouldn't have worn Air Jordans because
Celtics they didn't wear Air Jordans no
he he transcended the game those were
definitely the hottest shoe like you
know before that it was you know Adidas
and puma and you know the the fat laces
and and all that kind of that was very
much what Ben and I in our in our high
school we went you know there was one
school in our in our city so there were
three thousand kids it was really like
you know uh a good kind of cultural
Touchstone for kind of what was going on
like what was the cool music what was it
called and I remember those shoes
specifically just before the Jordans and
then the Jordans came and just changed
everything were you an athlete
no I was the first I was in the first
class to letter in theater
I had a varsity letter in theaters do
you get a letter jacket for that uh you
know you had to buy the jacket but I got
the letter and it had the little face of
comedy and tragedy on it but uh but we
had a great great great high school and
but again it was a really big school so
you know for some context you know
Cambridge where I grew where Ben and I
grew up was a basketball City Like Pat
Ewing uh lived on my street or I should
say I lived on Pat Street
um so Ben and I weren't making that
basketball team obviously you know when
we were there it was Ramil Robinson and
uh we'd win the state championship or we
were in it every year what do you
remember about Ewing on your block
well Pat the first game I ever saw in
the Boston Garden I was 10 and that was
Pat's senior year
um so he's I guess eight years older
than me so uh and I remember going to
the garden and and I knew you know it
was like this guy was from my hometown
he lived at the end of my street he was
uh you know he's a superstar already and
he you know that someday I was gonna go
to school where you know and so I was
cheering with the high school kids
um uh you know it was really exciting I
just remember it being really exciting
and I did and I remember walking by him
at like the River Festival down on
Memorial Drive and just you know being
all of four foot ten and walking by at
seven foot dude it's like it's like oh
my God yeah uh how does this movie get
how does this script get to you
I got Ben uh sent it to me he goes Ben
found it I I'm you'd have to ask him how
he found it I'm not I don't remember how
he found it or how he came across it but
he said I read this thing he goes it's
great he goes we should do this we can
do it really quickly you know it's ready
to go and
um and uh and I read it and it was and I
had that same every time I picked this
script up I was stuck for it's like when
you bump into Goodfellas on TV it's like
uh well I'm here for two hours
but the script felt like that it was
like oh it was just it was a page Turner
and it was really exciting with all
these characters really it was a great
yeah a great kind of Ensemble group to
you know it was fun thinking about all
right who are we going to get to fill
out this cast and the parts were all
just terrific well you talked about this
after the screening in New York that
working with Viola Davis it's like this
is easy I mean she's dude we're wrapped
by 10 30 in the morning and now we got
to figure out what we're doing for lunch
she was she was that great as she plays
Michael Jordan's mom yeah yeah yeah and
that actually came from Michael you know
Ben went to see him before you know
before we got to uh pregnant with the
movie we basically Ben said well I
really need MJ's blessing like I I don't
you know we we didn't want to do if he
said look guys this that's not how
anything happened don't just just leave
it alone we would have left it alone
um but actually what ended up happening
was
Ben went to to to talk to him and he
ended up Ben called me after I was in
New York I couldn't go down to Florida
to see him my kid had something that day
I can't remember but I was waiting for
Ben's call to see if we were going to go
forward with this thing and he goes he
goes I got amazing news he goes I got
great news and I got some bad news I go
okay and he goes the great news is he
goes he and he started to detail what
Michael had told him Michael was very
specific about George raveling being in
the movie like that was where he first
heard about Nike who he heard it from uh
and Howard white uh you know as as being
these absolutely pivotal people in uh at
that time and and Beyond but uh but
specifically at that time and then he
Ben was trying to get details about how
everything went down and and Michael
talked about his mother and he talked
about his mother
uh in with such reverence
um and you know that it really was
really moving for Ben and and Ben
started to realize how pivotal she was
like for him and this deal in his life
and everything and uh and Ben said okay
well uh all right well it's clearly he's
thinking to himself well we're gonna we
gotta we gotta rework you know we got to
rework the script but he goes who should
who should play your mom and and before
he got the sentence out Jordan was like
Viola Davis and he said he was like
absolutely like that's it and so Ben
said so the great news he goes I know
exactly what we got to do like I have
great direction for our rewrite we have
these two new characters to bring it and
we really need to expand Dolores Jordan
and really make this hers and
I said well great what's the bad news he
goes we have to get Viola
Davis we can't do the movie I was like
oh okay you know and I was like I think
I said to him at that point I was like
that's like having to get Michael Jordan
on your basketball team you know she's
an American treasure so uh but we rolled
up our sleeves and really went to work
on the rewrite and and uh and tried to
write her apart that was worthy of her
you know and uh and thankfully she she
she agreed to do it and I mean as you
saw she's just I mean she's just and it
is that thing I mean I joke but it's you
know I'd show up for work and do you
know a
seven page scene with her and when you
do a seven page scene normally in movies
a two-page scene is the longest you'll
do uh but I do with a long long scene
with Viola and you know we'd be done by
10 30 in the morning and I've just been
in one of the best scenes I've ever been
in in my career and she's like you know
we're like what else are we gonna do
today like I I think that just happened
like
um it's really awesome working with
somebody of that caliber how important
is it to meet the person that you're
going to portray in the movie
it depends you know I've done it both
ways where I've played someone and not
met them and played someone and met them
um you know you're never it's not an
imitation and it's not
um
what this movie really was trying to do
was capture the spirit of these people
right it's you know we don't look like
them we're not uh you know we're not
it's not about specifically who said
what and I you know because 40 years
later everyone's got their own Narrative
of how exactly everything happened and
um but I did speak with sunny and and
and and what was really interesting
um because you know famously this the
you know after this whole Landmark deal
I mean this I mean completely historic
deal happened
um you know these relationships all
frayed and fractured and
you know kind of these people got fired
and people left him but you know there
was like a sense of betrayal and
acrimony and all this stuff but what
Sonny said was look this time that
you're making this movie about
was the most joyful time you know this
was just he goes we were the just great
friends and I think they all understand
now I mean you know sunny and Phil are
they're in their 80s and looking back
like at what an amazing thing that they
accomplished and and
that all that stuff feels like it's kind
of water under the bridge at least when
they kind of look back now I think they
it's not all jumbled together the way it
might have been 30 40 years ago it's
it's like
they're very generous about each other
at least in my in the conversations I've
had with them
it's not exactly De Niro and Raging Bull
but you did gain some weight here uh
playing Sonny Vaquero how it's not
stressful gaining weight it's stressful
losing weight yeah I know exactly I I
can look at a pizza and gain 20 pounds
that's easy uh but I but Ben also had a
body suit for me he wanted to put a
little extra heft on me so so I I put on
probably 20 and then put on a bodysuit
on top of that to because there was
really it was mostly just for this one
for one joke in the in the movie uh
where Phil and I are having a
conversation about running and and we
just like the idea that you know this
guy worked at a Running Company right it
never ran it never ran and uh you know
the idea was so loathsome to him
um so it was really all for that kind of
physical gag we're talking to Matt Damon
the movie is air he portrays Sonny
Vaccaro last time we had John I think we
got you in trouble in Boston what did I
do uh you oh God Brady as a buccaneer
and you were going to root for Brady in
Tampa like I think he's Unapologetic I'm
Unapologetic okay yeah yeah yeah I love
that guy I love that guy it didn't mean
I didn't root for the past I've
obviously watched the Pats and read for
the patch but I just really cheer on you
know had David Ortiz been traded to
another team I still would have kept an
eye on him and cared about how he did
you know when someone does that much for
your team in your city who's made you
cry
who's made you cry with joy more Brady
or your Red Sox well the 2004 Red Sox I
I I I I think I I said this when it
happened when when I drove back up to
Boston for the parade and I remember
running up to Boylston Street and by
myself because my dad my brother
everybody we were getting my nephews we
were getting everybody to gather to walk
down to the river to watch the duck
boats as they went in but I sprinted up
to Boylston Street to see the same as
they came down that way by myself
and found myself outside like a shaman
or some Bank just standing on the side
of the road and crying
out of gratitude for those guys I love
those guys that I mean you know and all
the subsequent teams but that but that
first one was I can't even I think
people from Boston could tell you it was
like it relieved a kind of psychic
I it changed it changed us at a
fundamental level because you know my
grandfather didn't see the Red Sox win
it's like the Cubs Matt it changed the
lovable losing Cubs and it changed those
fans like it's weird that that you
almost Embrace Who You Are
and then it's gone
and now who are you
yeah but who we were were not just
people who lost but people who came so
heartbreakingly close and lost right
which was a painful state to live in
right and so it did and I agree it
changed it changed I prob I follow it
less now you know what I mean I I I but
I don't know that that's a bad thing you
know what I mean I feel like I have a
healthier
I don't know it it really yeah the story
that I told myself I was 34 when they
won
they're 33. the story that I told myself
for all those years was
it's never going to happen it's never
going to happen so yeah I mean it did it
it it it brought me to tears for sure
I'll leave you with this could you see a
scenario where you do what Cruz did for
Top Gun with Jason Bourne that maybe
Jason Bourne is 60 and comes out of
retirement or hiding yeah I could
certainly see if we could if we could
think up a good story you know it would
um I would definitely do it I love that
character I love it's been great to me
and and uh I love the story so
you know if there was if there was a way
to do it I'm not I'm not against it it's
nice to see you know the 60 year old Tom
doesn't look 60 by the way I don't know
how old he is he looks like he's and
he's doing all of his own stunts I mean
he ruins it for you guys
I I don't even try I mean I I had dinner
with him 15 or so years ago and I asked
him about the one where he ran around
the outside of the building you know and
that mission impossible and he started
the story by saying the safety guy told
me I couldn't do it and I go okay and he
goes so I get another safety guy
you're the king yeah uh congrats on the
movie uh enjoyed it always great to talk
to you again yeah thanks Dan appreciate
it Matt Damon all right he didn't poo
poo your script there Bourne Identity
bring it back maybe wait like seven more
years ten more years come back and then
he could be
his version Jason Bourne's version of
Maverick top gun Maverick yeah Jason
Bourne back for one more payday